نبدا بفرحه فوز المنتخب المغربي اسود
الاطلسي او اسود الاطلس على نظيره
البلجيكي بنتيجه اثنين صفر ضمن منافسات
المجموعه السادسه في كاس العالم لكره
القدم وسجل البديلان عبد الحميد سبيري
وزكريا ابو خلال
الشوط الثاني ليحقق المغرب مفاجاه كبيره
يحتل بها صداره مجموعتي مؤقتا برصيد اربع
نقاط بعد تعادل في الجوله الاولى مع وصيف
العالم كرواتيا كما يعزز الفوز فرص المغرب
في تاهل لدور السادس عشر بكاس العالم لاول
مره منذ عام 1986
وبهذه النتيجه عمت احتفالات كبيره
الجماهير المغربيه التي عبرت عن سعادتها
بهذا الانجاز خاصه وان اسود الاطلسي
اصبحوا قبقوسين او ادنى من بلوغ الدور
الثاني من المونديال
[موسيقى]
من الدوحه ينضم الينا مفرد العربيه ليث
بازاري ليس فرحه مشجعي المنتخب المغربي
ننقلها معكم مباشره تفضل
نعم يا ليال نحن مازلنا في الملعب ملعب
الثمامه هنا في الدوحه انتهت المباراه قبل
اقل من ساعه من الان وكما تشاهدين اللون
الاحمر يحيط به المغاربه هم يحتفلون بشكل
كبير الفوز اللقب يعني الحلم الحلم بربح
كاس العالم
شكرا للفريق المغربي على الفوز دياله
اليوم بصراحه حسن فرحانين بزاف بزاف جينا
نشجعوا الفريق المغربي والصراحه شكرا
القدر على تنظيم ديالها صراحه كل شيء كان
في المستوى العالي جدا جدا
والعيال كما تعرفين الملعب
بس هذا الملعب من هنا خلفيه يعني من كثر
ما في احتفالات سوف تقام الليل انا متاكد
سوف يغادر الملعب ال 44,000 همم متفرج او
مشجع المنتخب المغربي سوف يغادرون في
ساعات متاخره من الليل البعض منهم سينطلق
ههه
[تصفيق]
ويريدون باي طريقه ان يذهب الى الى هذه
الى هذه الى الى يعني الى المباراه
المباراه الاخرى ويعمل طبعا ان همم
يكون هناك تعادل همم قريبا او على الاقل
الفوز على الفوز على كندا ولكن الجماهير
يعني
ولكن شده الفرحه ما زالت مستمره وهناك
اشخاص يطلبون مني الميكروفون للقول الكثير
عن هذا المنتخب المغربي العظيم صراحه
صراحه
ويمكن ان نشاهدها معك ليس على كل حال سن
نعود اليك لمتابعه مجريات المباريات
الاخرى وكل اجواء كاس العالم من العاصمه
الدوحه شكرا لك